what's the order at taco bell
i'm very like um simple you know so
i don't like the double decker taco
supreme because it's like they put way
too much sour cream in it it's a lot it
[ __ ] up my stomach and it's also i
don't need the extra layer of tortilla
around the shell
i think it's just
very liberacy of them to do that
it's like hey i'm here
you know what i mean
and they're doing like you know i don't
like it right i like simple old-school
taco bell so i i enjoyed they're just
they're regular taco i get a burrito and
i'll get a burrito
i think british tell her the special
order do you know what okay
let me ask you do you like taco bell i i
do but i don't go very often okay
but how old are you
why no i'm because i i think age has a
lot to do with this next question that's
why okay um i have a trivia what's the
one thing you can order at taco bell
that's not on the menu but they'll make
and it's always been on the menu mexican
pizza no is that one though
they took it off
but can you still order it
i've never tried
[Laughter]
because the mexican pizza i think has
elements in it they just don't have any
more so they can't make it
they have tortillas
what's the shell the the pizza shell
part is different it's a tortilla it's
not why are you arguing with the chefs
no no it's this is not chef [ __ ] right
this is this is poor man [ __ ] oh i yeah
yeah and i'm telling you that the shell
of the mexican pizza is something that
they don't use in the other
ingredients
i mean other um items so they wouldn't
just have it like just in case oh no
it's off the middle but just in case
somebody orders it i don't think that
that's the case all right okay i don't
argue with you but it's but oh no i'm
not done with your mexican pizza
[ __ ] i actually the only reason i
knew how to say mexican pizza was
seasoned ground beef two flour tortillas
he's right
[ __ ] you idiots
i have tortillas
okay let me ask you something right now
okay a flower tortilla right can be many
things
please
no it'll it's always a [ __ ] flower
tortilla it's always a [ __ ] flower
tortilla right
we know that right but it's you know how
like sometimes let me ask you this
let me ask you this right so it's like
you know how you go to a mexican
restaurant right and you order potato
not potent not potato chips but tortilla
chips right yeah some of them are like
you know harder right and then some of
them they'll put two or three of them in
the salad or whatever that has a
completely different structure and
crispiness corn and flour tortillas yes
yeah yeah corn has corn is has more
structure when deep fried when you when
you fry when you fry a flour tortilla
it's more light and fluffy right okay so
what i'm just saying that the the i know
but the flour for
the flour tortilla in the mexican pizza
is [ __ ] fried yes it's crispy and
they don't have a fryer that they come
pre-packaged that way probably
wait wait george is trying to fight you
you know what you're a producer
you're a producer and you shut the [ __ ]
up right now all right you're not a
panelist you're not a guest
and you shut the [ __ ] right now i know
what i'm talking about i eat a taco bell
i feel a vegetarian in the midwest where
there's only one thing you could eat at
taco bell that's true
you guys know what i'm talking about
right these people do not they're
ignorant and they don't know what
they're talking about so fans back me up
on this all right and i know i'm the
leader you guys know i'm the leader
wait i have a question go ahead okay so
when you came on the show i knew of you
because of mad tv right oh my god okay
there's gonna be this is
right here go ahead no no there's not
it's actually a legitimate okay yeah and
my mom knows you yeah which she
absolutely adores you yeah so you have a
lovely white woman thank you she loves
you hello judy hello judy say hello judy
i love you yes um she knows you from
what's the other show hawaii five-o
[Music]
yeah
sorry
see it's like it almost felt good
you know it would have felt good if you
got the show right okay but but the
whole thing of the k what what do you
keep saying something king
some kids left kings
okay so everyone on [ __ ] social media
kept writing it i was like i don't
understand can you give me a little
backstory of what this is oh number one
i'll just tell you this right now that
means you don't know who the [ __ ] what
kind of show this is and what the show
is you never listen to that's your mind
your fans are gonna
all right no she's a nice lady okay guys
so be easy but my point is this is that
it was an old joke where i said a long
time ago when the whole woke thing came
up yeah you know i mean that i was the
opposite of woke i'm slept so then
people just started calling me the slept
yeah and i sleep a lot as well coupled
with the fact that he does sleep in okay
people got it oh yeah okay so that very
exciting pizza go back
okay so you're wrong about it and i just
want everyone to know that so that's
that so i'm going to tell you what's on
the menu that's not on the menu that you
can order right and i'll tell you why
this makes sense it's called the
encharito
all it is is and it was i think on the
original menu all it is is a bean
burrito
which they see they already have it
right and then ranchero sauce on top
which they already have
right so they're not going to be like
oh we could just make that right
with a mexican pizza they don't have the
hard
crispy tortilla shell what's that did
you already tell her the encharito i
just said enchoritos what is it
beans burrito enchilada sauce it's a
bean burrito and they just put enchilada
sauce on it in a black so as a
vegetarian from the midwest have you
ever had the encharito no well
yeah see that so
again then again i want to say this that
reiterates that it reiterates and
reaffirms my opinion about you
and [ __ ] taco bell you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about i
have to say this though and i'll give
you a compliment
i met your baby like him
you baby yesterday right
like the baby good job it's normal
looking
so congratulations i thought it was
gonna be all [ __ ] up
right second of all
i'm really um liking your shoe game
oh wow okay
what we were we were having a huge fight
upstairs with my niece and bobby
about george's appearance we were like
george is a handsome guy and you're like
in what [ __ ] world yeah i know i
think so he's very happy coming from the
lesbian you have no idea
all right you have no room
okay valid valid